I'm Nancy ruther associate director of
the Macmillan Center and I am delighted
to welcome you all to we don't know
which reunion this is so it's the first
of many in the future how's that before
we and Ian Shapiro our director will be
here tomorrow flying back from the great
state of Ohio this evening so you will
see him tomorrow and before we got
started with the meet of the reunion I
wanted to thank Felicia Spencer and
Kathy sulkus who have been responsible
for pulling this all together so
wherever they are thank you so we hope
that the events will give you ample
opportunity to mix and mingle and get
reacquainted with each other
or make new friendships and also renew
and perhaps quench a little bit of that
intellectual curiosity that brought you
all to study with us a few years ago
many years ago or are still studying
with us I guess let me just give you a
few logistics tomorrow breakfast will
start at 8:30 and the panel's we hope
will start at 9:00 and we will have the
raffle if you haven't gotten your raffle
ticket yet you can pick one up upstairs
at the registration desk we'll do the
raffle tomorrow at lunchtime at noon and
there are a number of Saturday events
that the different area studies councils
have arranged to bring you in to their
particular parts of the Yale world so I
hope you will look for those sign up for
them or show up at the times that are
listed up at the registration desk if
anybody was excited about playing soccer
in picking teams for the hegemon sand
the preemptive strikers I regret to tell
you that they have been struck by health
problems so that there will not be a
soccer game tomorrow but Brazilian
Akshay dancing is quite athletic so is
Julia here Julia or not
can you stand up Julia can tell you more
about that at the reception later on if
you want to know the Yale Journal of
International Affairs the graduate
student publication will be around
tomorrow is there anybody there from the
journal in the purple sweater you can
look for her at the reception as well
there's an African art tour and
treasures of East Asia anybody from
African Studies no okay
for East Asian Studies they've got a
great set of events planned Abbi Newman
standing on the steps you can look for
her the gamelan music room
that's a South Asian Southeast Asian
instrument and the tour of the Yale
campus okay so look for those tomorrow
sign up and we hope you'll enjoy it and
then end the day with the African chorus
and more food and drink throughout the
day but without further ado I just
wanted to turn the floor over to Gustav
Ranas with whom I had the privilege of
working for six plus years when he was
director of then the Yale Center for
International and area studies before we
had the great good fortune to be renamed
the Macmillan Center and he is the Frank
ultra professor of international
economics emeritus now but still quite
active so I feel very privileged that we
were able to get him to introduce our
keynote speaker for this evening Paul
Kennedy so Gus to you
Thank You Nancy I think it was eight and
a half years but seems like eight six to
you my cup runneth over this afternoon
for two reasons one is that I have a
chance to welcome your back many of you
came through these portals when I was
temporary landlord of this place and the
second and more important reason is
because I feel honored to introduce
keynote speaker and the pleasure would
be all yours dinner in a little while
Paul Kennedy is a good example of what's
called Brain Gain I won't talk about the
Twain just again Paul came to us from
from in Venice you know in AD three I
think it was and he really has made a
big impact here and yeah he is not only
the chair Justin Dilworth professor of
history and director of international
studies international security studies
but he's made an impact in terms of his
popularity as a lecturer his impact on
graduate students in general many of you
know about the impact he's written more
than 20 books many of the early books
were on British diplomatic diplomacy one
kind another I'm not going to read them
all it would take some of his time but
everybody in this business is entitled
to a home one and he's had a real home
one and a few triples the home run as
many of you know is the rise and fall of
the great powers which went into 23
languages and 2 million copies
probably more by now and the way things
are going now he may still be proven
right in terms of what happens to the
great powers he's being modest I
remember it being in the hotel or karoku
in Tokyo during the heyday of this home
one of his and I was was a lot of
buzzing going on in the foyer and I said
what's going on he says Oh professor
Kennedy is here and he's being fitted
for lunch and he's giving a talk and I
think this happened all over the world
at that time was a huge huge impact
still reverberating and I think that
unfortunately he may be right
he also wrote a tuple preparing for the
21st century and most recently another
triple the Parliament of man
I think these books are both four sided
and farsighted and the the honors that
have come to him multiple honors
including being a fellow at the
Institute for Advanced Study at
Princeton in a fellow at the Alexander
von Humboldt Estonian born many others
which again I won't enumerate for lack
of time of course we Americans even
though I'm not a native-born I'm aware
of the special feature of British
honours so I can't resist mentioned he's
a commander of the most excellent Order
of the British Empire but I I want to
repeat that the biggest honor is the one
he's received right here in terms of the
acclaim is received by colleagues and
and and students including his work on
grand strategy which is become very
popular he's not just an ivory tower
historian he's also been in the real
world he's worked on UN reform he's
advised President Clinton and
boutros-ghali he doesn't fit the usual
terminologies of liberal or conservative
I would rather say he's a man who fits
the title of courageous
I remember well the Sunday after 9/11
and a few of us were asked to say
something about the events and a very
few of us who dare to say or ask why do
they hate us so much
it was not a popular thing to ask not to
ask as he did what would happen if we
were reversed
everybody was reversed what would be our
reaction then and I think it was a very
courageous thing for him to say and I
think I've seen this before in in his
character last I want to say there's
another side to Professor Kennedy called
soft power or softness I like to think
of it as a very nice characteristic he
cares about people who are less
fortunate and we are he's been involved
in kitchen soup kitchens he also has
waste
many of his speak of peace I'm sure he's
doing the same thing today it is quite a
sacrifice and in general I think he's
been active on that front which many
people don't know about now when he
first gave his title for his paper there
was an something missing which is no
longer in the title but I want to
mention anyway
I'll give you the current title great
power libraries transformational
challenges and institutional responses
earlier version has an added note says a
three-legged stool I think the three
legs from previous books and I think
unlike many three-legged stools this one
is a very sturdy stool
I think it's not gonna fall down in fact
I predict that this is going to be the
seed of another book with that I like to
introduce you to Paul Kennedy
thank you
Thank You Nancy and thanks to all the
staff who arranged this Gus thank you
for very kind quite excessive
introduction still you said something
which pleases me we're still in the I
came here 24 years ago an export of mrs.
Thatcher we started to downtown soup
kitchen 24 years ago I'm not happy to
report that it was as busy as ever on
Wednesday lunchtime but one of the
challenges of being at a major research
university in a in a city environment is
the chance to do something other than
what you would do at Princeton or Davos
which is to get into the real world
which is on the streets of New Haven
much much better place incidentally than
many of you here will recall when you
were doing your masters programs in the
1980s or 1990s incredibly better Gustin
is from Marx is actually stolen a bit of
my my first Thunder if that be the word
what I'm gonna try and do in this talk
is offer some musing some ponderings on
some of the areas with big areas of
international affairs and international
studies in today's world
it may seem a little self-indulgent
because it will start off in the next
slide was reference to those three works
which Gus mentioned the great power
rivalries the transnational challenges
and
the institutional responses but let me
tell you a little about the origin of
this I thought I would bring it to you
as the second audience of some remarks
which I was asked to make to a group of
international investors over in LA just
about a month ago very smart very
intelligent folks they're managing
large-scale pension investment funds
like the University of California
Teachers Union pension fund you can just
start to imagine how many billions that
is and they have to go carefully and
these were the people in particular
whose portfolio was to invest him in
real estate and they had come to see
over the past 25 years at like
everything else you could you had to put
your eggs and different baskets and
therefore they were now increasingly
investing in real estate outside of
California outside of the United States
that was their expertise what they
wanted to know was not specifically what
any of course I couldn't say anything
about you know this section of Shanghai
is a better investment better than that
section of Shanghai but generally how
how would they think about international
affairs in the broadest sense of the
word and in the broadest sense of what
what we think we teach in the panoply of
courses which are offered under the
umbrella of the Macmillan Center
International Security Studies and
political science and other places at
Yale how could one describe the the
forest or the wood for them rather than
describing a particular tree or
particular branch which is what we
academics are really rather guilty of
doing that is over specialization we're
not alone and not of course not but we
do tend to over specialize that you if I
go along to the renowned
Genomics department at yale there will
be somebody who was yes an economist but
then he or she will say well I'm a
development economist and I'm a
development economist with special
reference to the Caribbean or to
Southeast Asia if I go to talk to my
fellow military historians I will bump
into somebody who for the past 25 years
has never left the realm of the
anglo-dutch Wars of the 17th century
that's his area that's his forest that's
really his tree or branch so I was
thinking of one way in which I could
provoke these executives to think about
the difficulty of our describing the
funny changing shape of international
affairs was to was to actually go back
I'm not trying to do this in a
self-indulgent or autobiographical way
but to go back to certain experiences I
had since I came to Yale in the 1980s
I came with Gus got it right I came in
1983 as the deal was professor I was a
classically trained diplomatic military
strategic historian I was halfway
through writing my book on the rise and
fall of the great powers I'd written
about five or six or whatever earlier
books on anglo-german relations on
British naval mastery this was to be the
big one as it were when it came out and
to my utter astonishment was seized upon
because of the sad a whimsical
reflections in the final chapter of the
book which you know needn't have been in
from that the author's viewpoint but
when it was seized upon became a
national bestseller an international
bestseller because it suggested that the
big challenge for the United States and
the Soviet Union was how to
relative decline the critics have never
ever understood the word relative I
found myself challenged from all
different directions which we you know
modest and humble academics don't
usually get challenged from having to
testify before the Senate Foreign
Relations Committee or the House Armed
Services Committee going down to a
meeting
Brookings famous think tank in
Washington before an audience of 200
economists in may 1988 who wanted to
debate my ideas about the relationship
between economic technological power
relative strength on the one hand and
military and great power strengths on
the other hand in the midst of that
evening debate I well remember
economists getting up and saying turning
around angrily to his colleagues and
saying I don't know why you're bothering
with this book it's just a real really
professor Kennedy's were in a very
traditional dead white man account of
great power rivalries state-centered
government-centered why didn't he spend
and last eight years not on this sort of
ball you know boring
Bismarck Ian stuff but on the great
things which are happening and which
cross borders transnational trends
forces technologies migration crime 24
hour a day trading and the other 199 of
the economists turned around and his
guys savaged him and I think may have
defenestrated him I are not quite sure I
didn't know his name I've never met him
but as I came back on the Amtrak I
started thinking you know well actually
I don't really know much about these
transnational trans forces developments
which nation-states increasingly cannot
control so
avid reader of the economist and the
Financial Times and being one of us
persons who was taught by my great
mentor on military history serve as our
little heart to mark newspaper articles
and clip them out and put them in files
I started a file called global trends by
the middle of the year my file on global
trends was getting so big I started
subdividing it to global demographics
global finance and capital flows global
environmental issues when my legendary
editor from Random House Jason Epstein
said what are you going to do for an
encore I said well this is gonna sound
odd to you Jason but I think I like to
write about what this guy at Brookings
challenged me to write about and so I
then moved for next four or five years
into the book preparing for the 21st
century I was a diversion I wanted to
get back to a book on international
politics a book on the second world war
and other things like that but we went
ahead and it came out in 1993 when it
came out I was so relieved fire after
fire of statistics on development
third-world wydad why was it that Korea
and Ghana had the same GDP per capita in
1956 but 35 years later Korea 20 times
the GDP of all of that stuff was going
into my cavernous basement in the hope
that the rats would eventually you know
chomp at the bits get rid of it some way
and I got a phone call just after I come
back from walking in the Lake District
and it was from the Secretary General's
Office and the Ford Foundation to say
that in 1993 August 1993 it was lessened
two years before the 50th anniversary of
the United Nations signed the Charter if
you remember in June 1945 the UN was
under colossal pressure the number of
peacekeeping operations has gone from
nine to nineteen and three years the
South was complaining because the North
was obsessed with security issues rather
than development or poverty issues
there's no chance that anybody in the
Secretary General's Office could handle
the possibility of creating a report on
the long-term future of the UN looking
back to see what it had done okay what
it had done badly what it should get out
of what it perhaps needed more resources
on so the Ford Foundation which helped
the UN in the Falcor report the other
falker report on un financing had
spotted the brochure which I am kreuz
Russert had created on UN studies at
Yale and so the Ford didn't want to do
this report Department of peacekeeping
operations and the Secretariat couldn't
do it so we were asked to do it and that
was the phone call which came in to me
at 10:31 on Friday morning the 13th of
August 1983 why when my wife came back
from wherever she was
she said you look a bit dazed I said yes
I feel a bit dazed I just been asked to
write put together an international
commission and write a report on the
long-term future of United Nations and
she said well you're mad
and I said well well I think I agree but
I don't think I can turn down as
Secretary General of the UN so I and
Bruce worked on this for next few years
we produced our report the Yale Ford
Foundation report on the United Nations
in its second half century we brought it
along to boutros-ghali who by that stage
was a man in deep trouble we were in
deep trouble Gus will remember that in
that period where we were trying to
think optimistically about the long-term
future of the UN they came a triple 1e
of Kosovo reven itza and the Balkans of
Mogadishu and especially of Rwanda
Burundi by November 1994 the Congress
had hurtled itself recklessly in my
opinion to the right and the Republicans
were in charge of the entire Affairs 64
of those entering members of the
Congress in November 1994 didn't have a
passport they'd never been abroad they
weren't planning to go abroad they
boasted to their constituents that they
weren't interested in abroad and now
they were going on the House Armed
Services Committee and the Foreign
Affairs committees in any case
boutros-ghali had fallen out of favor
with the State Department with Madeline
he was desperately trying to get a
second term and couldn't see that just
wasn't going to happen so when we came
along with our Yale report on the
long-term future of the UN and presented
it to him with our radical proposals for
security council membership reform for
scrapping the ECOSOC and replacing it
with something else when we offered it
to him it was like offering him roadkill
I mean it was like skunk food he
teachers didn't want to see it he had
reneged on his promise to take it to San
Francisco in June 1995 and some of us
spent about the next year talking to
governments and London and Delhi etc
about this and and then we put it all in
the files and actually and there may be
in the basement of this building
somewhere in the archives I wouldn't
advise I wouldn't bother going to seek
them but there they are I resolved that
I spent you might say wasted three years
of my time because I picked up a phone
and at Friday afternoon Friday morning
and so decided to write this book which
came out last year on the past present
and future of the United Nations now why
am I being kind of ordered by graphic
graphical and self-indulgent it's
because and what's happened knowing what
I was going to talk about Gus picked it
up there these represent three of the
larger areas of study of International
Affairs or trying to understand what's
going on in the world they're not the
only ones many of you would think well
there should be a book on international
human rights there there should be a
book more on international financial and
commercial issues there but as I tried
to explain to you I sort of hopped from
one book to the other not exactly of my
own volition but being provoked into the
second book and and being requested into
the third book but when I was earlier
this week putting thoughts together for
this talk Nancy it occurred to me the
trilogy or the three-legged stool which
part of which disappeared from the Navy
under title was it turned out not to be
a bad idea of presenting thoughts and
panoramas to the investment executives
over on the west coast a month ago
because as I said most of us look at
International Affairs from our narrow
specialized viewpoint we're either in
security studies or when international
political economy or we're in
international organization or we're in
international human rights or women's
issues the softer agenda or we're
interested in the NGOs and international
affairs and what I was trying to convey
to them was that you know we are all
working in this in these areas but
somehow they do fit together and if they
don't fit together we're probably in a
world which is in trouble
so I don't have many powerpoints to
offer you this afternoon you'll be
relieved to hear but I thought I would
make remarks about the first stool the
sake of this first leg of a stool the
second leg and and the third leg Gus and
in a way are echoing what those three
works tried to cover try to do the first
area therefore is that of the
traditional world of a great powers one
of my favorite juxtaposition photographs
I suppose with the GIS and the Red Army
infantry shaking hands on the banks of a
river Elbe and early May 1945
the collapse of the Third Reich if you
like the culmination point or the
apotheosis of at least in European great
tower or nation-state terms a
culmination of almost 400 years of great
power rivalry since Francis the first of
France smashed into Italy in the late
15th century since the formation of the
European nation
States symbolic in another way as most
of you know because it was the two
outlier countries a two outlier flank
powers which were meeting in the heart
of Europe the world was moving from one
system to another from a multipolar
world to a bipolar world the the one on
the right is of course what happens but
here's the optimism this is the
handshakes are occurring while the
delegates already in San Francisco in
May 1945 are hammering out the final
wording of the Charter but this is just
a few years later in Berlin
confrontation time 1960 American tanks
on one side of a divided Soviet tanks on
the other side of a divide came fairly
close but there was nothing unusual to
that which is why you know people like
George Kennan and Henry Kissinger and
Brzezinski found this an understandable
world who was the world which they knew
about is a world in which kissing who
wrote about Mehta nation Castle ray
cannon who wrote about Bismarck as well
as Kissinger it was understandable was
taken to another level you had the
peculiar problem of thinking through the
nuclear age but this was a traditional
form of study and of understanding
international affairs and if you think
that that area has been obliterated in
recent years because of our concern with
non-state actors and threats then I
would suggest you go along to the Naval
War College in Newport Rhode Island
where those guys have China on the brain
they still think in terms they will
their mental world in other words and I
was trying to explain this to these
executives who are thinking of putting
tens of billions of dollars of invest
in the Far East the mental world of our
strategic planners at the Pentagon at
the National Defense University at the
Naval War College is indeed that of how
to deal with the next Challenger the
next contender for the number one
position so they're getting really
fixated by the way in which China has
been developing weapon systems which are
not directly symmetrical to our large
aircraft carrier task groups but in fact
our deliberately asymmetrical
sea-skimming 400 kilometer range
missiles which make no no US Admiral
wants to go anywhere close to Taiwan
right now in the middle of a crisis
they're doing what my colleague and
Gus's colleague Paul Bracken would call
a strategy of see denial India and China
are pushing us further and further out
the days of gunboat diplomacy in the
Yangtze went away I guess in 1949 but
they've really gone away this time now
this is their mental world I'm not
saying it's my mental world but we have
to understand that in this area of
international affairs there are people
who are paid to work day and night
sinking office this sucker is really
interesting it's it's a diesel engined
submarine with German technology
including technology from Blom on Voss
and the the Rostock I think or Hamburg
the EFT in other words the people who
put together the superb German
submarines in the last two years of the
Second World War for the Battle of the
Atlantic are now putting together these
submarines and the Chinese are buying
the technology why because they are
ultra quired diesel
Marines you cannot pick them up they're
coated with the same technology that we
code our b-1 bombers and our stealth
fighters with we don't build diesel
engine submarines because they're not
sexy enough
you wouldn't get enough profit to Groton
New London General Dynamics and local
representatives all liberal in this
state until it comes to defense orders
it wouldn't work so what what's
happening is that these craft can get
close to our big warships without us
being able to detect them even our los
angeles-class attack submarines the kind
of hunt for red october submarines can't
get clear so what is happening and in
this dimension or as Joan I would argue
on this chessboard of great power
strategic vision of International
Affairs nothing much is changing you're
just getting another challenging power
coming up to eyeball the leading or the
hegemonic power nothing new there what
about those other dimensions so are the
other parts of the leg or the three legs
or the three dimensions or the the three
books the transnational challenges the
ones I tried to cover in preparing for
the 21st century
a triple illustration and one could put
up another 10 or 15 transnational
challenges whether it be poverty whether
it be devastated burned out Amazonian
jungles weather could be poor polar
bears floating on shrinking ice floes
but I think you can get the sense of
this this is what the Brookings
economist was chiding me about in
a 1988 but I hadn't bothered thinking
about because I was so focused upon
great power decision-making I was so
focused upon foreign officers and State
Department's and Pentagon's and the
Pentagon's and foreign office cannot do
much about this this is this is part of
Arizona which was once a wonderful
incredibly well-timed New York Times
Sunday magazine of last of last last
Sunday just before the brush fires and
the wildfires on California leave a big
article called the perfect drought
issues many transnational issues that I
tried to point out and here the
international executives were more
understanding of it the the the
incredible interconnectedness and
internationalization of global capital
flows these folks standing well you know
somewhere in Bradford or Newcastle in
the north of England trying to get their
savings deposits out of their northern
Rock building their account with a
northern rock building society because
northern rock had decided some years ago
at wish to make more money than its
traditional investment instruments and
changes portfolio and it put a large
amount of cash into into subprime
mortgages did you like the music which
one was that
dancing on the on the Titanic as it were
what did they know about us subprime
mortgages in Florida nothing but the
knock-on effects went across the
Atlantic and are still going all the way
around we we're still to see some of the
results among the European banks of
they're having over hastily invested in
this instrument this dodgy instrument it
brings enormous profits it brings
enormous internationalization brings a
lot of a lot of jobs for those in the
field though many of those jobs that are
being tossed out in consequence of it
the internationalization of capital
explains that when you go to airports
you just see a certain type of person
waiting patiently the McDonald's etc for
news of the flight delay and others
going along to you know the Admirals
Club or the British Airways or the
Emirates first-class Club because they
are part of this international world
full of promise but not much controlled
despite everything which is being done
the most interesting thing to me I'd be
interested to talk with Gus about it
later is that it does seem to me that
every report that comes in about
stabilization measures like the three
big US banks creating a seventy-five
billion super fund which the stock
market foolishly saw as great news like
the seventh Cavalry coming the creation
of a super fund is an indication that
those guys know much more than we do
about how bad the situation is ditto the
European Central Bank the other driver
of global trends a big one that I've
chosen out of as I said a you know
panoply is the inexorable continued rise
of world population disproportionately
occurring in the less developed
countries of the world it's true that
the overall percentage population growth
rates have been going down and it's true
that some actually remarkable
stabilizations have occurred in
countries as widely spread as Brazil and
in part East Africa but the fact is that
unless all of the demographic experts
that we trust are wrong we're going to
see the global population go up from its
present 6.6 billion to roughly about
nine if you go for the higher estimate
rather than a median estimate ten
billion was 95% of he increases
occurring in countries which are under
severe strain structurally economically
environmentally so what do we do about
it
when I used to give talks about
preparing the 21st century you know Yale
clubs alumni associations knows about
all of these big broad transnational
global uncontrollable forces the most
common reaction I got especially from
the Yale alums was to look at each other
after my lecture on the Q&A and say
Jesus
because it seemed you know we're so
unavoidable so big if if national
governments couldn't deal with it well
who would deal with it and I guess
that's where I come to my third leg
if national governments cannot deal with
these broader forces for change
transformation some of which may be
beneficial some of which are undoubtedly
damaging then you have to go back to the
founding fathers of 1944 with the
international financial instruments at
Bretton Woods and to go back to thinking
of international security instruments
and as you well know and as I try to
describe in the Parliament of man book
the world Society has not just then but
in many later times and occasions
created a vast array of
instrumentalities to try to deal with
challenges and opportunities which are
by their very nature by their very
nature or international
yes each of the richer countries has
indeed the equivalent of USAID they have
their own relief agencies one of my sons
is currently employed by the Norwegian
relief agency when I tell friends he's
working for the NRA they liberal friends
get incredibly first about it in Somalia
you know Vikings in Somalia this is a
world that would be inexplicable to
people in the age of Bismarck or people
in the age of you know earlier great
power leaders people who understood
International Affairs to be that of
States and Prince
the gamut as some of you well know
because some of you have worked with
them the gamut of the agencies
responding to international crises in a
reactive way the UN peacekeepers there
in Eritrea or the gamut of more positive
responses of nation-building such as the
ballot boxes there in Cambodia and going
on to the more positive versus this is a
World Bank photo of World Bank rural
literacy programs I think in I can't
tell where think Kerala what some way
and some of the poorer provinces of of
India this gamut of responses is quite
quite staggering the number of
international instruments we have in
going from the technical agencies which
we rarely think about because they're
just dealing with things that happen
every day the international air you know
traffic control International Maritime
Organization I for some reason I get
almost every day an email from the
international maritime law institution
cited in Malta and it's about
developments and international maritime
law and regulation and you think well
wow you know what's I got to do with me
except that you then pick up the
Financial Times and discover that
eighty-seven percent of all world traded
goods go by sea they're responsible for
the law of the sea they're responsible
for the insurance policies they're
responsible for international agreements
on piracy down the East African coast or
no Malacca Straits and you realize well
we couldn't do without them some of the
agencies are definitely more political
more controversial and the whole issue a
of development aid on one hand
and B of peacekeeping and especially
peace enforcement on the other is a
story of you know two steps forward one
step back or as a pessimist would say
one step forward two steps back in many
cases the world may be changing such
that some of the instruments of 1945
will be less pertinent less useful kind
of interesting at this time of the
meeting of the Bretton Woods
institutions in Washington just a few
days ago to see some really serious
economic journalists
wondering if there was a future life for
the IMF because a large number of
countries chiefly boosted by oil
revenues just want to get away from the
conditionality strings of the IMF so
that the amount of loans given out by
the IMF right now the total is so so
much less than even ten years ago but
there they are the responses so it
sounds pretty pretty cozy and it sounds
in a way as if we've managed it we have
a three-legged stool and as many of you
know in all of those Grimm's fairy tales
and other things like that three-legged
stools are incredibly strong pretty hard
to break a three-legged stool you can
put a lot of weight on a three-legged
stool so we have the great power of
policies and governments which are still
there and massively responsible for what
happens to their citizens and massively
responsible for international treaties
we have on the second leg down from the
stool we have our attempts to understand
international change transformation
transnational issues but then we have
the third leg which are the
institutional responses so I am gonna
stop in a minute too
go for QA one could just stop here and
say okay we've got the ABC the
institutional responses actually relate
back to the great powers because it's
those government's which have created
the International responses it's those
governments especially on the Security
Council which have authorized the UN
peacekeeping or peace enforcement but
they're responding to transnational
trends like the need for increasing
literacy and the need for environmental
Accords environmental protection so
everywhere you look at it those three
legs seem to interconnect it therefore
sounds holistic but I'm I'm gonna end
with one final slide because I'm I'm
actually persuaded that there's more
still to be done I'm not convinced that
what we have here an institutional
responses allowed try to defend those
responses and defend those organizations
in a parliament of mine and lots of my
talks I'm not quite sure whether they
are going to survive the real big tests
of the next 10 20 30 years so I'm just
ending with one final cluster of slides
not so fast Kennedy you have not yet
reached your tena Sounion Parliament of
man you have not yet reached your
Commonwealth of Nations lapped
a law of Tennyson said in 1837 poem
Locksley Hall the pressures are coming
again
they're coming perhaps faster they're
coming in a broader way Security Council
has before dat the moment about six
possible peacekeeping peace enforcement
new mandates to consider even the
countries which have had a wonderful 65
year a track record of 60 year track
record of support for peacekeeping are
showing donor fatigue and donor fatigue
these days means not just donor fatigue
of the sort that Gus and I understood
when of word came out in the early 1990s
about fatigue and giving money for
peacekeeping or development the donor
fatigue is in providing contingents of
men and women for un operations or
police work or anything else like that
so this is what I tried to tell the
executives it was rather surreal but not
too often I I know Gus does this all the
time was not too often I'm you know
sitting in this luxurious
Hills hotel saying hi to Schwarzenegger
as he goes by in the other direction
well this is what I was trying to tell
them that in our world of describing
studying analyzing International Affairs
we have all become specialists we have
to but on the other hand every so often
if we try to describe what's happening
in our world our world of study to those
who are not in our world of study we
have the same intellectual obligation as
an international investment banker would
have to describe to us what is the
landscape and what is the shape what are
the challenges and what are the
different aspects of his world of
international banking so I this is my
reporting him as it were from talking to
the real estate investors but I it
seemed to me to fit as an address to you
all coming back to Yale and we're
grateful that you have done and are
doing coming back to Yale but coming
back after you've had the opportunity of
thinking about these larger intellectual
and global challenges but perhaps it was
worthwhile offering this to you because
as you marched on from your master's
degrees and your phd's you too were
forced by the pressures to to focus on a
particular part of the forest and the
wood and sometimes to forget the shape
of the overall structure of that
environment and the reason why Nancy and
Gus and others offer these renewal
sessions is to give you a chance to get
away from trading desks or wherever you
are at and to and to discuss and think
about the the bigger forest that is our
world of international affairs Thank You
Nancy yeah
yes I'm happy to do QA I should say that
I'm conscious that some of you have
travelled quite away I'm conscious that
all of you know that there are drinks
upstairs and snacks hot snacks in a
short while I promise we will not
overrun we might under run see who among
my former students is first to the bar I
have one or two I suspect will be there
first but let me take a few questions
and a few thoughts and get feedback I
saw yeah excuse me yes
there's there's a great traditional
British Foreign Office reply to any
awkward question like that and it it it
goes with great difficulty I seem to use
it for everything you know what's
happened to my missing dog where do we
find it well with great difficulty
getting out of Iraq is with great
difficulty anybody who claims that they
have the answer
whether it's slogging on forever oh it's
our colleague here at Yale general Odom
saying quit and run you bet none of
those seems to me politically feasible
realistic and so we're left in a really
messy situation so will the successor
administration be don't even ask me
about Iran
we have enough acts of folly over the
past few years without multiplying by
two right now I mean I write a monthly
column for the LA Times and the Chicago
Tribune syndicate which is chiefly goes
to foreign newspapers because the column
is about 1200 1300 words long and
American editors only once 600 words to
describe something complicated like
where's Putin's Russia going so I I look
back and see without any satisfaction at
all that I wrote against going into Iraq
then and I don't feel proud that we got
ourselves in a mess like that oh saying
I knew things were going to be bad but I
didn't know they're going to be this bad
I'm assuming that there will be some
form of staggered phased withdrawal I'm
assuming that there will be parts of the
country
which are relatively quiescent largely
because they are ethnically and
religiously homogenous I can't but think
though that is going to be an still a
continued amount of bloodshed I'm like
everybody else goggling at what's
happening on the turkey northern Iraq
frontier so I have no easy solutions
I've never met anybody who that I've
heard of and all of these conversations
over
dinner tables or whatever we we almost
wrecked a Thanksgiving dinner in Boston
last year by all of the members of my my
wife's extended family just getting so
annoyed at each other about different
proposals and that's happening across
the country I think we have to get out
one way or the other it's it's not just
contrary to the American traditions
it's just contrary to common sense I'm
not
despite the wall street journal'
characterizations of me not a British
Labour pinko or anything else like that
I actually approached this with rather
as kissing udders in Bismarck incensed
if we brought the German Chancellor back
and told him about today's world and
told him who the big powers were my
guess is that Bismarck would say well
okay you've got a stuck in Iraq does mr.
Putin's Russia want us to stay stuck in
Iraq any answer would be yes and he
would say well there's this big rising
power call the People's Republic of
China does it want us stuck in Iraq any
answer would be yes and then he would
say there's this other big Asian power
called India which is beginning to
spread its wings does it is it
advantage by our being stuck in Iraq and
the answer is yes as a Bismarck would
say well if if Russia or ones are stuck
in Iraq and China wants us stuck in Iraq
and India once it's stuck in Iraq and a
lot of others want us stuck in Iraq it's
time to start thinking of not being
stuck in Iraq so how you do it is the
$64,000 question and you know I still
think probably we are going to end up
following the proposals which are former
yearly Fareed Zakaria made in Newsweek
as long it goes about two years ago
which was we will pull back to a three
or four or five fortified areas and then
will and we will keep up with the
attempts of training rebuilding Iraqi
security forces and police forces but
all the public opinion polls say that
month after month we are less and less
popular in that country I can offer
little solace here and what's more I
think the UN can offer little solace
either take another question yes please
well I share the characterization
generally speaking that China
allow its ability to influence global
markets and to play a role on the
Security Council chiefly negative is
large and increasing it has not been if
you like carrying its its share
proportionate to where it's heading
that's not uncommon historically I mean
in the in the 19th century the United
States which was the booming economy
that was a boom and bust and boom and
bust economy was definitely not carrying
out its proportion of international
security or international institutional
obligations by 1914 the US GDP was equal
to that of all of the European states
but it was not much of a player to the
frustration of the British who felt they
had to carry our rolls which they would
have been more willing to carry out if
they had a US Navy which was willing to
help them the u.s. after 1919 goes back
to play that rather negative or
isolationist role so I don't think this
should surprise us what might surprise
us would be to take a yardstick of
China's responsibilities to or
relationships with the international
order in say 1995 and then come forward
to 12 years and you'd actually have a
quite an impressive list it would not be
much in the way of intervention in the
Middle East Chinese are too clever to
intervene in the Middle East would not
be in a way of much Security Council
contribution or peacekeeping
contribution but in the areas of concern
the Chinese leadership now I think
rather significant step-by-step
additions to
including areas where we complained
about 10 12 years ago intellectual
property rights patent law law of the
sea the more that China expands in
commercial and financial terms the more
becomes a stakeholder in an
international stable commercial and
financial environment and it's more if
if that weird book called the rise and
fall of great powers has any validity in
its arguments it's that the economic and
commercial and financial growth comes
first before the greater international
power ro which which follows along often
some generations behind so I think what
we're seeing is that China is it's still
cautious it's still new Rajic about
anything which offends chapter 2 section
7 of the Charter about no interference
in the internal affairs of any remember
governments but it's now realizing it
has stakes out there in Africa and in
Latin America that it simply didn't have
15-20 years ago I I don't know I think
they're pretty good card players say no
way their strengths are they know what
they want to avoid my concern is that we
may have a government in Washington
which really doesn't get the priorities
right I agree with you that China is
incredibly important yes ma'am
could you speak up yeah
yes sure this is a Gus trainers question
well I try to repeat what you said in
your two-headed question as I attempt a
stumbling answer to it I have no idea
whether the US government is secretly
quite happy as the dollar goes down in
international value most of the
financial press at the end of last week
had op eds in from international
economists monetary economists and
bankers saying that it will go down
further I don't see this you know
stopping mr. Cheney from shooting all
over Texas ranchers on the weekends he's
not losing sleep about that and it and
it is not surprising to me at certain
other governments think that this is
deliberate or intentional and the u.s.
is just not going to do it because it
will benefit Boeing visa vie Airbus in
sales of very large aircraft
dollar-denominated or euro denominated
as you well know the French especially
among the Europeans are being incest
incensed about this now but I I don't
know frankly I'm not quite sure the US
Treasury or the Federal Reserve Bank
possesses the instruments or the freedom
of maneuver to which would cause a rise
in the value of the dollar the only way
I can see is from my crude learning of
economics would be a significant rise in
interest rates which would drive the
Congress nuts and would definitely put
us into a recession in various already
troubled parts of the economy so I don't
see it happening you said what did I
learn or what did I come away thinking
about what the international community
could do in response to some of these
big transnational challenges which were
described in the report but and which I
tried to illustrate here Mike I came
away as a conclusion that
first of all we're gonna have to be a
lot smarter and a lot more realistic Oh
yell Ford report on you know the United
Nations in its second half century we
were under instructions from the great
German Bundesrat n from vysoké and from
the the other co-chairman was the
wonderful Pakistan prime minister who
took Pakistan from military rule to
democracy Marine Qureshi we were under
instructions to draft a very radical
structural changing report and so we did
you know adding a whole number of
countries to the permanent veto status
on the Security Council getting rid of
ECOSOC what what I and Bruce came to see
was that changing the Charter changing
the constitution of the UM is not the
way to go it's much easier to change the
US Constitution believe me than it is to
change the Charter the only one change
occurred I think 1964-65 raising the
number of rotating seats on the Security
Council from the original six rotating
seats with the five permanent raising it
from six to ten we've never done a
change in u.s. charter since then if you
look at the conditions for getting a
change which at the very end of the
Charter you'll understand why it's such
a big hurdle so if you're going to
improve things you're going to have to
think of what do you do practically in a
whole variety of areas whether it's
peacekeeping intelligence gathering of
impending crisis
pre positioning of forces medical
supplies various other responses so
you're not continually taken by surprise
the only people who've done this
seriously our northern neighbors the
Canadians up at Frederick and and New
Brunswick they are pre-positioned two
battalions trained for international
peacekeeping and police force so
if the sovereign Canadian government is
asked by the poor secretary-general who
has to go around with his cap in hand
whatever the Security Council announces
a new mandate if the sovereign Canadian
government says ok we can send one of
our battalions it can be out there in 36
hours this is what the Canadians learned
from the dreadful shameful experience of
general Dallaire in rwanda burundi in
1994 you've got to be ready they are all
sorts of ways which professor rainiest
know is much better than I of improving
coordination between the economic and
social agencies there are there's much
work and much really good work on the
ground being done in that realm which I
try to describe and probably not very
well in Chapter 7 of my book which is on
the role of international civic society
the NGOs for churches the liberal
foundations it's really surprising that
when you go to somewhere like Kenya or
the Caribbean it's not just the world
bank doing something or the UNDP it's
probably about 20 other groups and
organizations many of them increasingly
cooperating with each other or sharing
information so I'm not no I'm not
pessimistic about pushing forward at the
practical level I'm truly pessimistic
about any change in a constitutional
alteration of the Charter because the
hurdles for twin hurdles are just too
bad yes please sir
this is not my field at all I'm also
trying to say I
I pass are you is your question whether
the sheer size of those goods and
services could be amended in some legal
way taxation way structural way that
might be a reinforcing element to the
need for international cooperation ah
well I'm I'm really pleased
well you know some economists would say
that simply the year-on-year growth of
the US economy and of European Union
itself is assisting many many poorer
countries because of the demand for raw
materials I mean look at the price of
copper or vegetable oils or many other
of those things which of which we the
the extractors or the producers are
located in developing countries which
have seen a significant shift in their
inward capital flow because they have
these resources now the
environmentalists would get rather
worried about that so it's it's a more
complicated business if you meant other
than there are two other things which
which may be in what you're thinking
about what I'm stumbling to reply over
one is can we increase and use more
intelligently our USAID or other foreign
aid and I think the experts in the field
would come up with half a dozen nifty
ideas in which we could use it and they
would but it'd annoy a large number of
Nebraska farmers because it would be but
using a not just to purchase American
foodstuffs but it would be using aid for
infrastructural development or
healthcare development there was an idea
floated here but 15 18 years ago which
began professor Ennis will recall which
was since the world has globalized and
since there are enormous flows 24 hours
a day
a
and our planet of capital and therefore
currency exchanges why not a really
really minimal tax the Tobin tax named
after our great economist James Tobin
why not a minimal task you know tax of
like 0.01 cent on every dollar of things
which were exchanged Tobin I believe was
thinking of that tax whatever the rate
it was to be something which would
inhibit or deter currency speculation
rather than be a source of income for
international purposes but the turbine
tax idea was picked up by a large number
of international organization reformers
in the early 90s who thought that this
would mean it would generate even though
the tax itself would be very small a
volume of financial exchanges were so
large it would generate a pretty decent
flow of funds which could go via the
Bank of International Settlements to the
United Nations budget and take some of
the burden of nation-states the result
of that in this country was expressions
of utter outrage and venom from the US
Congress it was not then paying are
internationally due contributions to the
UN budget but it didn't want to see any
alternative source of income to the
International Organization who wanted to
have the power of the purse and the
power stranglehold so that idea which
may have led to possible flow possibly
larger flow of funds died in a dust run
about 1994-1995 had not heard it raised
again so I think you have the to the two
answers which would come back to you
putting aside this international
tax response would be that we actually
do the best when we keep our trade
barriers low and purchase from the
outside world and secondly we could do a
better job with the allocation of the
funds which are technically they're in a
Congressional Budget Office record of
how much foreign aid we give each year I
can take one more question I think and
then definitely not getting in between
you and your drinks
well let's try and pass that a bit I
don't think the world if we're talking
about the big powers and therefore the
permanent veto powers were five on the
Security Council they are not
necessarily paralyzed the they have
immense powers as given to them in you
know chapters 5 6 & 7 of the UN Charter
if the big five and then a majority of
the others vote for a certain thing or
demand a certain thing or mandate a
certain thing by international law and
by the fact that every one of a hundred
and ninety-two Nations signing into the
Charter said it would obey the Security
Council it's so the great powers do
carry duties and that leads to enormous
amount of disillusionment
therefore if you think of through little
Maude means that the interesting reform
proposals for increasing the number of
permanent veto powers may make it may
make the Security Council
more representative if it had say India
South Africa Brazil as permanent members
but it would mean there were eight big
powers who could do the cherry-picking
or could put a you know a stick in the
spokes of the wheel which is why some
smaller countries like Singapore are
against anybody else getting a permanent
veto seat it will just make it more
difficult to get consensus but I repeat
my point if they come together if they
agree on it if especially the p5
ambassadors walking down the corridor
agree that then they can get things done
second part very briefly if it is
paralyzed by this constitutional
capacity of negativism they have
negative powers not positive clouds it
is paralyzed by that increasingly in the
future will we look for other ways of
solving problems or will we look for
other structures I I don't think we will
look for other structures there may be a
more coherence and more commitment by
regional organizations which are already
there the organization of African Unity
for example could do more if the
sovereign states but I don't think it's
going to be in some new odd proposal
that we create a a World Coalition of
the Willing I think right now given the
state of
of the Willing would be a very very
small group of states in any case but I
think of what's going to happen is
somewhere along the lines of what I
suggested a few minutes ago which is if
if the central part if the Alec Council
of the Holy Roman Empire isn't
functioning very well then how do you
deal with this or that problem in the
Rhineland or Bavaria in the Baltic will
happen is translating that from the 18th
century to the 21st century you'll you
look for practical ways of doing it and
so I end a little bit more hopeful on
the peacekeeping part and so you may
think I should be the agenda piece of
the document from 1990 to assume the
sort of template of how to respond to a
security crisis that is to say you would
invoke Chapter six of the Charter and
the secretary-general uses good officers
or send a special diplomat negotiator
if the sides didn't agree of one side
began fighting you would then move to
economic sanctions and then you start
moving up the ladder to peace keeping
and if they got really bad and started
attacking the blue helmets you would go
to peace enforcement and there was your
template it was pretty much destroyed by
what went on in the Balkans Central
Africa
mogadishu people thought that
peacekeeping was then totally finished
and actually for a year - it was was a
Security Council backed off mandating
any peacekeeping or peace enforcement
and then it started coming back looking
at the Charter which is very nifty and
knew us about what the Security Council
made dudes who it may ask in and it
began to use some of the parts of the
Charter which hadn't been there if an
individual member of the Security
Council wish to go to the Security
Council and ask and volunteer to lead a
mandated UN operation the British in
Sierra Leone the Australians in East
Timor and then produced a local
coalition to follow it its lead there
and if the Security Council gave His
blessing it could do it if a regional
organisation volunteered to try to deal
with some crisis in Central America or
Africa it also could do it so I guess
the one part of my mind which is not
numbed by pessimism over our 21st my
mind a template for all they don't work
in some parts of the globe that worked
pretty well other parts of it no and I
think that's gonna be the story of the
21st century just like economic advance
and development is going to be a partial
one some areas will find it much easier
to become prosperous than others some
will find it that they can become stable
and free of war let's hope so
it's he he kept you from your drink I
think that's right and I should have
said that among the different
instruments being which which was looked
at from the 1993-94 onwards were
regional defense organizations you can
actually point to some of the later
wording in Chapter seven of the of the
UN Charter where it says using regional
organizations but we're in danger of
abusing that if it's used just because
the Pentagon and the White House don't
want to have an operation under the
Department of peacekeeping and the UN
and don't want it under the Security
Council and so they invoke this to get
NATO operations in the Balkans and NATO
operations in Afghanistan and may invoke
it in in various other places so I this
is a two-edged sword I don't think
anyone would protest at the use of
deployment of NATO forces in the Balkans
to bring peace there but everybody also
understood it was a hegemonic powers
decision because it wanted to use NATO
headquarter and organizational
structures which it knew
about and which it would be in control
of so there is a danger which many
Europeans are pretend of NATO being
regarded simply as an American tool for
US interests in different parts of the
world and you know it just look as if we
should get rid of a North Atlantic part
of a NATO acronym the wider and further
we go afield so I think it's a risk Gus
I just think it will or it we should not
be surprised if it's invoked again or
tried again by future US governments
thank you